You're probably asking yourselves,
if the event-driven model has
just one thread,
then how did it achieve concurrency?
In the multi-process and
the multi-threaded models,
we had each execution context,
whether it's a process or
a thread,
handle only one request at a time.
To achieve concurrency, we would simply
add multiple execution context, so
multiple processes or multiple threads.
And then, if necessar,y if we
have fewer CPUs than contexts,
then we would have to
context-switch among them.
The way the event-driven model achieves
concurrency is by interleaving
the processing of multiple requests,
within a same execution context.
Here in the event-driven model,
we have a single thread, and
the single thread switches its execution
among the processing that's required for
different requests.
Let's say we have a client request
coming into the system, so
it's a request for client C1.
And we receive a request for
a connection that gets dispatched,
the accept operation gets processed.
Then, we receive the actual request.
So it's an HTTP message that gets
processed, the message gets parsed,
we extract the files.
So now we actually need
to read the file and
we initiate I/O from
the reading file handler.
So at that point, the request for
client one has been processed through
several of these steps and it's
waiting on the disk I/O to complete.
Let's say, in the meantime,
two more requests have come in.
So client two and client three have
sent a request for a connection.
Let's say the client two
request was picked up first,
the connection was accepted, and
now for the processing of client two,
we need to wait for
the actual HTTP message to be received.
So the processing of client
two is waiting on an event
from the network that will have the HTTP
message that needs to be received.
And let's say client three,
its request has been accepted and
it's currently being handled,
so the client three request is in
the accept connection handler.
Some amount of time later,
the processing of
all of these three requests has
moved a little bit further along.
So the request for C3,
the accept connection was completed,
and now that request is waiting on
an event with the HTTP message.
The request for client two, that one,
perhaps, we're waiting on the disk I/O,
in order to read the file
that needs to be sent out.
And maybe the request for client C1,
already started sending the file in
chunks at a time, so blocks of
some number of bytes at a time.
So, it's waiting in one
of those iterations.
So, although we have only one
execution context, only one thread,
if we take a look, we have concurrent
execution of multiple client requests.
It just happens to be interleaved, given
that there's one execution context.
However, they're multiple,
at the same time,
multiple client requests being handled.